-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
Thank you for being here.
Thank you for watching.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Guys, it seems like there's
so much going on right now.
The Major League Baseball
playoffs are underway.
Tomorrow the movie
"Halloween Ends" comes out.
[ Cheering ]
Yeah.
This week,
former President Trump
made fraudulent claims
that other ex-presidents
stole documents as well.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And Burger King just debuted
a Ghost Pepper Whopper
with an orange bun.
[ Cheering and applause ]
I mean, there's a lot
to go over,
so let's jump in
and cover it all at once.
It's time for a "News Smash."
[ Suspenseful music plays ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
First up,
former President Trump.
He's spreading made-up stories
that Obama,
Clinton, and the Bushes
all stole classified documents.
Man, this guy
just will not go away.
Trump's basically the real-life
version of
Michael Myers.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Halloween Ends" is the
[ Whistle ]
13th movie in the franchise.
If you watch them all in a row,
it'd take over 20 hours,
which is basically the length of
A baseball game.
[ Laughter and applause ]
The playoffs are here,
but the Mets already got
knocked out.
Their fans are sick about it
and you know what else
will make you sick?
Burger King's...
[ Laughter and applause ]
with an orange bun.
[ Southern accent ]
That thing ain't natural.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I mean, seriously,
why would you want a bun
that's freakishly
Orange.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Whistling ]
Trump's gotten himself
into trouble
and, rather than tell the truth,
he just keeps telling
Whoppers.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's got
ghost peppers in the cheese.
This thing is so spicy,
it's guaranteed to give you the
Runs.
[ Laughter and applause ]
They are what you need
in the playoffs.
Without them,
you'll lose games and get
Eliminated.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Michael Myers
is a symbol of Halloween
and nothing says
"Halloween" more than
A pumpkin.
At this point --
[ Laughter and applause ]
At this point, Trump can't
even find a good lawyer.
Everyone that he texts just
Ghosts.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Those peppers will mess you up.
If your family eats those,
you'll all be feeling it in your
Ends. So, in conclusion...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Crack of the bat.
Don't eat that.
[ Laughter ]
Look who's back.
Dude is whack.
[ Cheering and applause ]
This has been a "News Smash."
♪♪
As I mentioned,
this weekend, "Halloween Ends,"
which is the 13th
and final movie
in the "Halloween" franchise,
hits theaters.
You can tell Michael Myers
is getting old
because, in this final film,
he runs for president.
[ Laughter and applause ]
You can tell Michael Myers
is getting old
because he needs someone
to cut his people for him.
[ Laughter and ohs ]
That's right, "Halloween Ends"
is about to hit theaters.
[ Laughter ]
That's a slow one,
but you get it eventually.
You know, it's not bad.
Even though it's the end
of Michael Myers,
they're already considering
some spinoffs
that sound just as terrifying.
For example, there's...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Then there's...
Next, there's...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Like, "I hope it's alright."
Next, there's...
Oh, my.
[ Laughter, oohs, and applause ]
Next, there's...
[ Laughter and applause ]
It just --
just just doesn't work.
Next, there's...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Oh, no!
And, finally, there's...
They're exactly as scary.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Switching gears, you guys see
this yesterday on Fox Business?
They were talking
about inflation
and one of the contributors
and a pretty wild complaint.
Watch this. This is real.
-You want to know
how bad inflation is?
Yesterday, yes, I had a nice
lunch at Taco Bell.
Cost me about $28
at Taco Bell for lunch.
-Wait a minute.
You spent $28 at Taco Bell
-Yeah.
-for just yourself?
-[ Laughs ]
-For lunch, yeah.
-Really?
-It's true.
-Okay.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter and applause ]
The only way Taco Bell costs $28
is if you include the weed
you buy in the parking lot.
[ Laughter and applause ]
That is it.
That is absolutely --
Seriously, if you ate $28 worth
of Taco Bell,
you wouldn't be on TV.
You'd be on a stretcher.
[ Laughter and applause ]
You know what I'm saying?
Hey, guys, I read that
Subway said that they've --
now experiencing
record-setting sales.
[ Oohs ]
Yep, Subway is doing great.
The CEO was like,
"Take that, real tuna."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Well, guys,
everyone loves TikTok,
but sometimes you don't have
time to watch a whole video,
that you just want to skip
right to the good part.
Well, it turns out you can.
For instance,
if you're watching a video,
you can skip this part --
[ Clanking ]
-Oh, Lord.
-And go right to this --
-Oh, God!
[ Rimshot ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
Let me -- another example.
You can skip this part --
-[ Laughs ]
-Oh, no!
Oh, no-o-o!
-And go right to this --
-Oh!
[ Rimshot ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's right,
you can skip this part --
-♪ This is how we do it ♪
-[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-No, dude,
get ready, get ready, get ready,
get ready, get ready,
get ready, get ready.
[ Laughter ]
And go right to this part --
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
No.
Want to see it again?
-Please, please.
[ Laughter ]
-The balance on that kid.
The balance!
[ Cheering and applause ]
According to a new poll,
Prince William
has been decrowned
as the world's sexiest bald man
[ Ohs ]
by Vin Diesel.
[ Laughter, oohs, and applause ]
And Vin Diesel actually
commented on it.
Listen to this.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
I don't know what he's --
He's lost his mind.
What is he talking about?
And finally, a French automaker
just unveiled
a new one-passenger
electric vehicle
that rides on three wheels
and can be driven
without a license.
Here it is.
Look at this.
Ooh, yeah.
Yeah.
It's called Le Death Trap.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Alright, guys,
we have a great show.